[Music]
that's
actually not even close to how loud i
snore apparently i snore
very loudly my name is george moats it
is my job to preserve
the american hamburger right but
you know things happen when the burger
goes out into the world i've often said
that technically to be a burger it has
to be ground beef
cook somehow and hang out i got a
street cleaner new york city keeping it
clean
where's my car crazy things can happen
when the burger goes out into the world
it can come back as something completely
different and that's exactly what
happened with this burger
the ramen burger the guy named kaizo
chimamoto
invented the ramen burger period keizo
is an intense character because he takes
a bowl of ramen
as seriously as i take the american
hamburger which basically makes him
the ramen version of me
the ramen burger is a pretty simple
concept
it's two buns made from ramen noodles
there's a burger patty arugula
scallions and a very special secret
shoyu sauce
that is incredibly intense and flavorful
that's the whole robin burger but the
original ramen burger
did not have beef in it at all it was
actually a piece of pork belly in there
so he decided to make
the burger better queso's ramen burger
became an overnight success
it traveled the world everybody knew
about the ramen burger everybody wanted
to get a ramen burger
it was a stunt burger that worked most
stunt burgers don't work they're crap
they're made to get people in a
restaurant
and they usually don't taste great case
in point the mac and cheeseburger
mac and cheeseburger sucks chrissy
teigen famously once said
all those burgers that are made for
instagram that actually taste like [ __ ]
should die except for the robin burger
thanks chrissy are you ready let's make
a ramen burger
five elements i think five right we have
one two three four
five one two five elements there's beef
obviously a beef patty
there is the ramen bun which was shipped
to me from california thank you queso
mmm those are yeasty oh wow
smell that it was really smelly that's
incredible
mmm yeast it's forming in some strange
way i don't know how he does it
it's almost like rubbery see that look
at that
queso do you have any suggestions for
the home cook that wants to make a ramen
bun
if you want to make a ramen bun at home
you have to use
it tastes good arugula yes it's arugula
you know why arugula has a peppery
sharp flavor to it it's great in a robin
burger there's also scallions
and probably one of the most important
elements to a ramen burger
unquestionably
is keizo's secret magic
shoyu sauce
it's very sweet too oh wow
oh you know what queso actually
bottled this sauce it's a secret in a
bottle
oh ready here we go okay what queso does
is he has pre-formed
fresh beef patties to make things easier
when he's making
thousands of them an hour where's my oh
here
have you lost your balls i lost my balls
see this beef beef is here so
it's like a two ounce patty they're
pretty small they're pretty thin i'm
going to use this wonderful look at this
patty press this is actually a patty
pressing machine that a friend of mine
gave me in argentina
it's so simple pressure
parchment paper patty
and there it is look at that round like
the butt ready
the buns also have to be toasted or
heated up a little bit right now they're
cold we're going to take a little bit of
sesame oil and we're going to oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] now if you can smell this
right now oh my goodness
my apartment smells like
apartment smells like a ramen trap right
now because oh [ __ ]
jesus you don't want to burn them
obviously you just want to get them
toasty
kind of what i'm doing looking pretty
good
[Music]
that's the appropriate response yes
sauce
onto the patty while it's on the flat
top
i want more make it more onto the bottom
of the bun
we're gonna put arugula you wouldn't
usually see me
putting arugula on a burger we got the
patty goes on top of the arugula
scallions raw and on top of that
goes the crown oh [ __ ] it's hot
oh
i can't quite eat this yet i'm going to
give it a second
oh my god wow case is a bit of a
genius i got to tell you that sauce is
something else
every element of the burger is working
towards that one goal
which is to taste similar to a bowl of
ramen
but it works this right here is an
amazing burger
but before we wrap the episode i want to
give you something very special can you
imagine if you took
my burger the oklahoma fried onion
burger and you mash it up with a ramen
burger what would you get
that's right you'd get an oklahoma fried
onion ramen burger
[Music]
but we've done this before actually
keizo and i were once invited to
indianapolis motor speedway
to make a mashup of our two burgers for
the
i'm a huge fan of racing so for me to be
able to be
on track at indianapolis making a burger
with my buddy keizo
was like it was too much to handle it
was a dream come true
we put the [ __ ] burger on the star
finish line
on the start finish line it was awesome
so for you
let's make one of those let's make the
ramen burger
mash up yeah safety first
oh i'm using a knob
i'm using a slicer on the slice onions
oh oh jesus one of the best way in order
to make a
proper oklahoma fried onion burger you
need onions
you need super super super almost
thinner than
paper onions so they cook fast let's do
[Music]
this
ready to go okay let's get this out of
here
which is salt my balls
right there see that and then i take
thin
sliced sweet vidalia onion
and let it kind of fall around the ball
don't put it on top of the ball let it
fall around the ball
and i smash it
those onions are going to crisp up ramen
buns
queso do you remember what it was like
at the indy motor speedway he got kind
of jealous when
i got to take a picture with you know
the reigning nascar champion
and he was cut out so it's cheese on the
flip sauce on top of the cheese
oh yeah okay i got
the fried onion patty some scallions in
there
and then the top [ __ ] hot
oh i remember okay so i remember
that's why they liked it so much
good wow damn that's good
oh that's good
i'll see you next time on burger scholar
sessions when we
go deeper even deeper into hamburger
history thanks for joining
[Music]
hey my name is george moats don't forget
to like and subscribe to first we feast
and get more episodes of burger scholar
right here
where